today on the matt wall show the media is
promoting the story of the facebook
whistleblower she was on 60 minutes last
night revealing alleged secrets about
the big tech giant but this story is not
exactly what it appears to be we'll talk
about that today also fauci says that
maybe just maybe we might be able to get
get back to normal by christmas but
maybe not and a democratic senator is
chased into a bathroom and recorded
inside the bathroom by crazed left-wing
activists and in our daily cancellation
we'll discuss a recent article arguing
that god needs new preferred pronouns
all of that and more today the matt wall
show
[Music]
[Applause]
we're going to talk today to start with
about one of the many companies uh
facebook which is certainly uh working
against us in the culture
and is is definitely not on our side
even as so many of us patronize it uh
and which is why i think it's a good
thing to start by talking about one of
the companies that is on our side and we
can be proud to support that's charity
mobile as an increasing number of
companies fall all over themselves
trying to appeal to the left wouldn't it
be nice to find one that supports your
values charity mobile is that company
it's the pro-life phone company they
partner with you to automatically
support the pro-life pro-family charity
of your choice with five percent off
your monthly plan price and they've sent
millions of dollars to charities so far
you could be a part of that and a lot of
other perks too you get new activations
and eligible accounts get a free cell
phone with free activation and free
shipping when you mention offer code
walsh charity mobile makes it easy to
switch you can keep your existing phone
you may even be able to keep your
existing phone number as well if you
need a no new phone no problem charity
mobile has a variety of options from
basic flip phones to low cost
smartphones for your to the latest 5g
phones i've got all of that so switch to
charity mobile and support the causes
you care about call them at
1-877-474-3662 or chat with them online
at charitymobile.com and mentor mention
offer code walsh
so last night 60 minutes had a lengthy
interview with uh francis haugen
formerly known as the
facebook whistleblower
haugen had worked for the the social
media company and during her time with
them she began leaking documents which
were supposed to expose the dark and
dirty details about facebook's internal
workings now there's no doubt that the
you know facebook's internal workings
are indeed dark and dirty there's no
question that it needs exposing as well
and i'm certainly not here to defend
facebook far from it but
this whistleblower story that the media
is uh is telling us
is not as simple as they want us to
believe
and we know that from the start because
they're the ones telling it now keep in
mind that the corporate media and
facebook are part of the same machine
the same system
a whistleblower that was really
interested in exposing that system
wouldn't be so warmly welcomed by it 60
minutes gave a platform to haugen and
you know the rest of the corporate media
has reported breathlessly on the things
that she revealed during that interview
and that's not how things would have
worked if halgan was really an avenger
for truth and justice as she's being
portrayed with with no political agenda
you know it seems like it shouldn't be
necessary to say this anymore but
somehow it is
you cannot trust a single thing the
corporate media tells you not a single
thing
the corporate media are storytellers
not especially good or engaging ones but
that's what they are they tell a story
a story about the world about society
about us about you and all of the news
that they report has to fit into that
story somewhere
if it doesn't they're not going to
report it and if they do report it
they'll report it in a way that gels
with the story we have to realize that
the relativists have long since taken
over our culture and what that means is
that our society is being run by people
who literally do not believe in the
truth
they don't believe in it as a concept
they don't think that the truth exists
the truth is whatever they tell us and
whatever they can get us to believe
and that's something to keep in mind as
we look at the story of the facebook
whistleblower haugen's basic charge is
that facebook promoted um misinformation
and divisive and unsafe content and that
it does all this for profit they put
profit over safety she says listen to
this
in 2018 haugen told us the root of
facebook's problem is in a change that
it made in 2018 to its algorithms the
programming that decides what you see on
your facebook news feed
so you know you have your phone you
might see only 100 pieces of content if
you sit and scroll off for you know five
minutes
but facebook has thousands of options it
could show you
the algorithm picks from those options
based on the kind of content you've
engaged with the most in the past and
one of the consequences of how facebook
is picking out that content today is it
is optimizing for content that gets
engagement or reaction but its own
research is showing
that content that is hateful that is
divisive that is polarizing
it's easier to inspire people to anger
than it is to other emotions
misinformation angry content
is enticing to people and
keeps them on the platform yes facebook
has realized that
if they change the algorithm to be safer
people will spend less time on the site
they'll click on less ads they'll make
less money now here's the problem uh
most of that is is certainly true
facebook does promote divisive content
and misinformation but remember that
haugen and the 60 minutes reporter scott
pelley are on the same team they're part
of the same system
and that means they're speaking in code
to each other and to the audience what
they mean when they say divisive content
and misinformation is right-wing content
these words are all interchangeable in
their minds according to the story that
they're telling right it is after all
angry divisive and false content that's
propelled hundreds of blm riots millions
of people today now believe that guys
like michael brown are martyrs and cops
are nazi assassins out hunting and
murdering black men that america is a
systemically racist dystopia where it's
essentially legal for white people to
kill non-white people i mean people
believe this
and it is thanks to the work done by
both social media and the corporate
media hand in hand but when haugen talks
about dangerous and unsafe content she's
not referring to any of that if she was
she wouldn't be on 60 minutes for her
it's all about the right wing
perspective that's all it is
and she finally makes that clear by
tying everything back to the
quote-unquote insurrection complaining
that facebook had shut down the
so-called civic integrity units before
january 6. haugen said quote they told
us we're dissolving civic integrity like
they basically said oh good we made it
through the election there wasn't any
riots we can get we can get rid of civic
integrity now fast forward a couple
months we got the interest in the
insurrection
and so there it is
if she had linked facebook to the
capitol riot and also the blm riots
then we might be able to trust her
motives a bit more but then again if she
had done that we never would have seen
this interview
we see it because she's on the same
ideological team as the people who are
amplifying her she's on the same team as
facebook too which is why i don't even
buy that she is any kind of
whistleblower at all
facebook already tries to suppress
conservative content that's what it
wants to do
yes right-wing content is successful on
the platform relatively speaking and
this is you know the left uses this
absurdly to claim that facebook is
biased in favor of conservatives because
they point to how successful the daily
wire is for example on facebook
that's only because it's the content
people want to see that's why we're
successful
the company can only go so far in
suppressing the very content that people
using its platform want to access
it would like to go further in that
regard no doubt
and the pressure from this whistleblower
gives them the onus to do so
best case scenario for them would be
legislation forcing them to suppress it
the social media companies would like
very much to control the information
that you can access the ideas that you
can encounter the opinions that you hear
they already do in large part and yet
iconoclastic voices still sneak through
that's in spite of big tech's efforts
not because of them
the media feels the same way the reason
that they hate social media at least as
it's currently constructed
is because it gives people an avenue to
ideas that the corporate media has not
sanctioned the corporate media believes
that it's entitled to be the gatekeepers
determining what you believe what you're
told who is and especially who is doing
the telling
when they talk about the dangers of
social media that's what they mean it's
the danger of them losing
control and that brings us to the other
big revelation from the whistleblower
that social media especially sites like
instagram are harmful to kids here's uh
haugen on that listen
one of the facebook internal studies
that you found talks about how instagram
harms teenage girls oh yeah
one study says 13 and a half percent of
teen girls say instagram makes thoughts
of suicide worse
17 percent of teen girls say instagram
makes eating disorders worse and what's
super tragic is facebook's own research
says
as these young women
begin to consume this eating disorder
content they get more and more depressed
and it actually makes them use the app
more
and so they end up in this feedback
cycle where they hate their bodies more
and more
facebook's own research says
it is not just that instagram is
dangerous for teenagers that it harms
teenagers is that it is distinctly worse
than other forms of social media
facebook said just last week
it would postpone plans to create an
instagram for younger children
again i mean this is certainly true
social media is bad for kids
but is the media really worried about
your kids
if they were they'd be more concerned
about the fact that millions of
nine-year-olds are accessing hardcore
porn through pornhub and similar sites
besides when it comes to your kids using
social media there's a pretty simple
solution
as i've as i've argued in the past don't
give them smartphones on average kids
are now given their first smartphone at
the age of 10. that means millions are
getting them at nine eight seven even
younger there's no valid reason for it
oh you want to be able to get a hold of
your kid at any moment well you know i
think that's a bit excessive but fine
get him a flip phone with with no
internet access they still sell those
why does he need a phone with internet
and apps and games at the age of 8 or 10
or 11 or 12 or 13
but does he ever need one
why would you ever buy him one before he
has a job and is able to buy it for
himself answer there is no good answer
he doesn't need a smartphone no child in
history has needed a smartphone which is
which is how so many children manage to
survive without them
and i've had this discussion with
parents many times and the only
justification i've ever heard
is that uh well the world is different
now and uh and this is what kids do you
know they all have phones
yeah it is what they do
they do it because we allow them to do
it
we don't just allow it we facilitate it
fund it we make actual financial
sacrifices to ensure that they can have
this device that will destroy their
ability to relate with you other human
beings and have a normal childhood
why do we sit here as parents acting
utterly powerless to exercise any
influence over the children we're
raising who runs your household who owns
everything and makes all the money
if you don't want your 10 year old to
spend his entire childhood staring
lifelessly into the void like some kind
of lobotomy patient patient you have
absolute power to impose that desire on
him just don't buy him a phone it's very
simple
what's he gonna do beat you up
rob a bank so he can buy buy one himself
well that would at least be some form of
physical activity
so what are you afraid of why are people
so petrified of not obeying their
child's every demand
the only defense of the phone itself is
that
maybe it won't be that bad well if i
oversee their phone habits maybe they
won't be completely addicted to it
but they will become completely addicted
to it and anyway in that defense you
have admitted that nothing really good
or constructive will come from the phone
you've conceded that it's a bad thing by
and large your only hope is that it
won't be so bad
so that's the answer or part of the
answer a big part
when it comes to social media's effects
on kids
but the 60 minutes report never even
mentions parents
it never acknowledges the possibility
that we might be able to address some of
these problems on our own in our own
homes
that's because it's not interested in
solving problems
not the actual problems anyway
it's interested only in telling its
story
and convincing us to believe it
and we need to all be smarter than that
now let's get to our
five headlines
[Music]
now quick word from 40 days for life you
know the new texas law banning abortion
has abortion advocates going insane and
that's good news but you need to be
prepared as abortion is coming up in
daily conversation more now than ever uh
more now than ever so if you're
struggling on what to say and how to say
it when abortion is the topic of
conversation you need to check out a
recent new book what to say when the
complete new guide to discussing
abortion since its release should
release it's already been
number one amazon new new release a
number two amazon bestseller and it's
already on its second printing and
that's because it's a very easy book to
use and it's very useful it tells you
what to say what not to say and it gives
you the proven arguments that have
worked with everybody people on the
fence abortion supporters even planned
parenthood workers the book is from 40
days for life which is the largest
grassroots pro-life organization in the
world they've held peaceful visuals
outside abortion facilities in a
thousand cities in 64 countries and
they've already helped to convert the
hearts of 221 abortion workers so they
really know their stuff which is why you
got to go check out what to say when the
complete new guide to discussing
abortion go to amazon or get it directly
from 40 days for life at
40daysforlife.com
a couple things before we jump into the
headlines i just i i saw this uh just a
second ago
that there was a terrible tragedy uh
really unfortunate situation where
another george floyd statue was uh
vandalized
um there was it's it's not funny i would
never
laugh about it
um it's more of a nervous laughter you
know because
uh this is not the first time this has
happened it's like every time a george
floyd statue goes up it's vandalized
very quickly
and uh there's video there's a guy
skateboarding this is this was in um
union square
in new york and it was like this this
big monument to george floyd
you know the the guy who uh
barged into a woman's home at gunpoint
and robbed her
which is the only significant thing he
ever did in his life
the only thing that made any real impact
was that he didn't do anything else
um just a you know a violent felon and
drug addict and then he died
and that's why we have monument to him
but so apparently this skateboarder guy
was you know felt like
he wasn't very happy about the fact that
we have this big monument
to this violent felon who contributed
nothing positive to society at all
and so he he vandalized it and it's all
on tape and
man
there are still other monuments out
there of george floyd that have not been
vandalized yet
and i would never say
that if you come across any monument or
mural of george george floyd you should
do exactly the same thing i would never
say that
i would never say that
i would never say it
okay
and uh
okay also one other note i was in dc
yesterday
or this past weekend
and
the the mask cultists in dc are just
it's probably the worst city as far as
the mass cult goes
it's absolutely out of control there
um
that's one of those places where i was
actually yelled at by at least one
person who said put your mask on
very very simply like that and then i
just said no and kept walking
i've i have found the simplicity i've
i've worked on different responses in
these situations where someone's like i
just wear your mask put your mask on
and there are different comebacks you
can come up with but i think the
simplicity of just saying no and keep on
and just keep walking
i find that to be the most powerful
and it's it's especially bad now in uh
in
this this
coveted panic has made elevators has
turned elevators into elevators were
already awkward
and now that's that's awkward on
steroids because of of covet
i don't know how often you've been on
elevators while this is happening it
kind of depends where you are regionally
but people feel like they have to ask
permission to come on the elevator with
you now
if you get on the elevator without
asking
you know that scene now is a social faux
pas
and so it sort of flipped the other way
and i'm starting to enjoy it
because now i get on an elevator without
asking especially without my mask on and
the other people on elevator will crowd
to the other side like huddling in a
corner especially in a place like dc
and i have come to enjoy that you have
to i guess you have to find
ways to enjoy these sorts of things now
on a i think on a similar note dr fauci
was
doing an interview as he uh as he as he
so often likes to do and he was asked
if we might be able to get back to
normal maybe we'll be past all this
stuff with the masks and the elevators
and everything uh by christmas can we
get back to normal by christmas
of 2021
and if this feels like deja vu we were
having the exact same conversation
before christmas of 2020. and back then
he said uh maybe we'll see
and fast forward a year and he's saying
the same thing let's listen
but we can gather for christmas or it's
just too soon to tell
you know margaret we it's just too soon
to tell we've just got to concentrating
on continuing to get those numbers down
and not try to jump ahead by weeks or
months and say what we're going to do at
a particular time
so maybe maybe we could get back to
normal by christmas
which is always funny to those of us who
have been normal since last christmas
and since before that
those of us who never stopped living a
normal life but what i will say is
uh
now i don't have this experience in my
family so i can't relate to it
thankfully
all the people in my immediate family
anyway are are sane people so i've i
have all sane people in my family which
is very nice
so no one in my family has been waiting
around for fouchy to give them
permission
to gather together for a family reunion
or to get together for the holidays no
one's been doing that
in my family
but if someone in your family is still
doing that i don't care who it is
if there's someone in your family who's
still sitting there waiting
say hey guys we can't make christmas
plans yet because fauci hasn't given us
the go ahead
then you're better off without them at
the family gatherings anyway
you got to see we got to be at a point
now where you see this as a blessing
because we you you've just weeded out
the people who are so mentally and
emotionally unbalanced
that it's better not to have them there
so i wouldn't be worried about this at
all
go do what you want to do if there's
anyone in your family anyone who's still
even now is hesitant
about getting together with you because
fauci hasn't said so then it's it's
better off just just
move forward without them
you have no choice now
uh also fauci over the weekend had some
thoughts on
on your responsibility
to society had a little bit of lecture
about and he's been doing this more now
how do we balance freedom
uh versus our responsibility to society
and he had some more thoughts about that
listen
but you are a member of society
and as a member of society
reaping all the benefits of being a
member of society you have a
responsibility
to society
and i think each of us particularly in
the context
of a pandemic that's killing
millions of people
you have got to look at it and say there
comes a time
when you do have to give up
what you consider your individual right
of making your own decision
for the greater good of society uh well
well no you don't that's that's the
exact opposite of the of the the ideas
that lay at the foundation of this
country
it's the exact opposite
uh and he's he's outright saying that
well give up give up your give up your
freedoms and your rights for for society
and the other problem is you notice how
he's not saying
because on the left they don't have
language for patriotism
so he's not saying uh well give up your
rights for the good of the country
i wouldn't agree with that either
because especially if you're living in a
country that's founded on the notion of
human rights
you can't give up your human rights for
the good of that country
because you're undermining the very
thing it was founded upon
so you're destroying the country for its
own good which doesn't make any sense at
all
but um
but he's not you notice how they don't
say that he's not saying
uh uh it's it's for the good of of the
country
or even like western civilization or
anything like that it's just this broad
kind of amorphous concept of
society
what do you even mean by that what are
you referring to so we're left with this
kind of generalized amorphous idea of of
society not the country but society
which of course raises the question of
what exactly are you talking about
our duty to
society in general what what what
precisely are you referring to
and it doesn't matter what he's
referring to because again in this
country we don't we don't you don't
sacrifice your basic human rights
there's there's nothing that's more
important than that
uh
but even so you notice again what the
left always does and it's it's effective
it's there they're always framing things
around the notion of duty and
responsibility
moral obligation
calling you to make sacrifices
now they're always calling you to make
the wrong kinds of sacrifices
they're asking you to sacrifice the
wrong things for the sake of the wrong
things
and their ideas about our moral
obligations are completely twisted and
perverse
and same for our responsibilities and
our duties but
that's always the way they frame their
messaging
and it's it's compelling to people
and this is why i'm always saying to the
right that we we need to pick up on that
and realize because for for for too long
on the right
we we've had this idea that well you
can't talk you know we don't want to
talk about obligations responsibilities
sacrifice because that's scary to people
uh you know people don't want to make
sacrifices so let's just always be let's
talk about nothing but their rights and
and all of that
but rights and responsibilities are two
sides of the same coin you can't have
one without the other
and this is something that's compelling
to people
you call people to make sacrifices
you talk about what their
responsibilities are
especially in our society today where
people are lost with no sense of purpose
this is the kind of message they're
looking for
and they're they only get it from the
left that's the only place they get it
listen to alexandria casey cortez speak
or bernie sanders
or anyone in the squad
when they're when they are
arguing in favor of their policies and
their positions it's always well we need
to do this because it's the right thing
yeah it may require sacrifices but we
need to do it because it's right it's
moral
and still conservatives are afraid to
speak in the same language
which is a shame because we we actually
are the ones who have a notion about
what what our our real responsibilities
as human beings and americans actually
are
and we have or we should have
an understanding of objective moral
truth
and so we could be the ones representing
that
what are what are our actual moral
obligations
say this all the time when it comes to
the pro-life conversation
it it amazes me
that when we're talking about abortion
why abortion is wrong
you hardly ever hear
pro-lifers say anything about parental
obligation
you you almost never hear this you never
hear them say well
no you you have a responsibility to your
kids
yeah i i understand you don't want to be
responsible for them but you are you
have a responsibility to them
it's a very basic a fundamental message
that we're afraid to say
and so we we we surrender all that
ground and all that language to the left
and they use it effectively
and when you're talking about
responsibilities and obligations it's
always going to appear that you have the
stronger position you have the more
serious position
this has been the trick for for um
communists
for decades and decades
you know communists are always talking
about our what's making sacrifices for
the greater good our obligations to
society and to our brothers and sisters
our comrades
and that stuff
is very
compelling to a lot of people especially
young people
the um the christian churches that have
figured this out
they reap the rewards because
you go into these these really
conservative
serious christian churches like like
especially the latin mass
if you're catholic
and that's where you'll actually hear
messages about moral obligation and when
you look out in the pews what do you see
you see tons of young families they're
hungry for that message
all right so kristen cinema is a
democrat senator from arizona she has
upset leftists because she's not
supporting biden's agenda all the way so
i'm sure you followed some of that
i needed to to review all of it she's
not showing proper deference to to um
the leftist agenda they're mad at her so
they tracked her down at arizona state
in fact the day before this they were at
her house
uh with megaphones harassing her
and uh that didn't they felt like they
didn't get the message through so they
they they tracked her down at arizona
state
and they caught her in the um
in the hallway on the way to the
bathroom
and they followed her into the bathroom
to heckle her and let's listen to some
of that
okay i'll be back
we want to talk to you real quick
actually i am heading out
but um right now is a real moment that
our people need in order for us to be
able to talk about what's really
happening we need a buildback better
plan right now
we we're not done work we need solutions
and to build that better plan need has
the solutions that we need we knocked on
doors for you to get you elected and
just how we got you elected we can get
you out of office if you don't support
what you promised us we need seven
million citizenship for seven million we
need the
benefit right now
my name is blanca i was brought here to
the united states when i was three years
old and in 2010 my grandparents both got
deported because of sc 1070 and i'm here
because i definitely believe that we
need this pathway to citizenship my
grandfather passed away two weeks ago
and i was not able to go to mexico and
visit him because there is no pathway to
citizenship and if we have the
opportunity to pass it right now then we
need to do it because there's millions
of undocumented people just like me who
share the same story or even worse
things that happened to them because of
sb 1070.
uh so these are at least one of them is
an illegal alien
[Music]
tracking a sitting u.s senator into the
bathroom
now
you you can
only imagine the reaction if this was a
member of the uh of the squad let's say
this is alexandria cortez
we think about some right-wing
protesters who are upset at alexandria
casey cortez
um and they they find her in the hallway
they don't even have to follow her into
the bathroom
if they just followed her down the
hallway for 10 feet
and said congresswoman can we talk to
you that would be enough right there
that would that would be another
insurrection
and alexandria casa cortez would be
doing instagram live videos about it and
crying and saying oh she almost died and
they
telling wild stories about how they came
after her with uh you know nunchucks and
and spears
and that's if they just
think about them following her into the
bathroom
and she's in the stall and they're
yelling at her
and there's a guy in there too
the guy came into the bathroom
uh now
you can you could only imagine imagine
the response from the media
but in this case it's uh cinema who is
also a democrat
but she's being harassed by people
that are who are further to the left
than she is
and the basic rule of course is that
whoever's further to the left is always
right
and so these people are being uh are
being
defended for the most part
by lots of people on the left
and in the media
meanwhile one of these people confesses
to being an illegal immigrant
now in what other country could you get
away with that in what other country
could you
be there illegally
and then track down a government
official
on video
and confess on video to being there
illegally and then harass them in a
bathroom
and the next day you're still in the
country
what other nation maybe i should ask
what other non what non-western nation
let's see i could see that in plenty of
european countries but in what in what
non-western country could you do that
do you think of a non-western country
where i could go there illegally
find one of their government officials
and start and start harassing them and
demanding that they make me legal follow
them into a bathroom
deportation would be the least of my
worries if i did that
but here uh you know she's the next day
she's painted as a victim
if we were a serious country
that night she would have immigrant
immigration officials at her door
carting her butt back to mexico that's
what they would be doing in a serious
country you're here illegal illegally
you're harassing a government official
in the bathroom
and you're also recording them in a
bathroom which last time i checked
recording someone in a bathroom against
their consent is a crime
that's what a serious country would do
but we're not a serious country
and so she's allowed to get away with
this and she's also allowed to get away
with it um
she's allowed to get away with it
fundamentally because
uh the belief on the left is that if
you're not fully
on board with the agenda
then you you're not worthy of any basic
respect or dignity or anything
there's no treatment of you that could
be considered too harsh or out of bounds
you deserve all of it
by the way uh
let's see
someone else this is sophia marjanovic
who is
i guess one of the people
who was involved in this altercation and
she posted on facebook
talking about this and she said i will
speak about the controversy regarding
following senator cinema into the
bathroom when i have the time none of
you have a right to tone police my
desperate demands for labor protections
after what i have endured as a human
trafficking survivor due to the ef'd up
gig economy for now connect with the
fact that you are on stolen indigenous
land and indigenous women and children
go missing and murdered because we don't
have access to stable jobs stable
housing clean water clean food or stable
decent health care despite the fact that
indigenous people have upheld our end of
the treaty and assimilating and getting
educated arizona's among the top three
states in the u.s where indigenous women
and children go missing and murdered
give my indigenous relatives to the
south of the u.s mexican border
citizenship now
uh
now i i i'm not i'm not sure what she
means by a human human trafficking
survivor because of the gig economy
is she saying that she was in the gig
economy and that's tantamount to human
trafficking i suppose
but here we go back to this uh this
stolen land
idea
which which doesn't doesn't even make
any sense you're saying that this this
entire country is illegitimate
it's stolen
and therefore you demand that people be
made official citizens of this
illegitimate government on this
illegitimate land that we don't belong
in the first place
so you you want more people to come in
and take advantage of this all this
stolen man land and the stolen uh you
know
rewards that were reaping that doesn't
make sense to me but of course it's not
supposed to make sense
this is an emotional temper tantrum
and they feel entitled i mean this again
also
the speed
with which people develop this sense of
entitlement
after getting to this country is really
amazing
people come here and immediately feel
entitled to everything
you know there was i don't think we ever
talked about this but
there was
one of the afghan a few weeks ago one of
the afghan refugees
on a military base who had been who had
been saved from his country brought over
here
you know arms extended open
even if not everybody feels that way but
the government anyway extended and he
brought over here and uh he had supposed
to went viral on twitter because he was
complaining about the meals that he had
been given
you know he's brought he's brought out
of his country brought to this country
offered a home
and as soon as he gets here he's
complaining because because the meals at
the refugee you know
the military base they're giving
refugees not good enough
it's not enough oh and also he
complained that the wi-fi speed was too
slow
it's it's farcical really
uh and this has become you know i talk
all the time about as americans what
what is what unifies us what brings us
all together
right we talk about if if we are one
country
what is it that ties all of us together
aside from the fact that we all live in
the same geographical sort of
basic region of the globe
especially when we can't we can't rely
on that distinction anymore because the
borders don't exist
and uh what is it and and we hold no
real value we have no values in common
if if there's anything
that ties everyone together or most
people in this country together it's the
sense of entitlement
all right finally this is from yahoo i
just love the way that this is written
it says criminal charges charges were
filed against teresha lucas a 30 year
old black woman in an unexpected turn of
events
this week authorities in georgia
revealed they believe a black woman is
behind the racially charged notes that
have been terrorizing her neighborhood
since last december a douglasville
georgia neighborhood has been gripped in
fear due to racially charged messages
that have anonymously anonymously been
left in mailboxes of residents of color
but now officials say police said that
they have made an arrest and the alleged
culprit is not who anyone would have
expected wednesday the douglasville
police department confirmed that they
had filed criminal charges against
teresha lucas lucas is a 30 year old
black woman who they believe threatened
people in her community while posing as
a ku klux klan member
in an unexpected turn of events uh okay
i remember that part uh let's see there
was another funny part here
uh in the notes threats were made to
turn down home to burn down homes and
kill their occupants the author of these
disturbing messages also made it a point
to describe themselves as a six feet
tall white male with a long red beard
who did not live in the neighborhood
shouldn't that have been your first clue
that something is slightly amiss here
for all these residents who are
allegedly terrified
well the first clue is that you're
getting the racist notes from a kkk
member in the first place when there are
you know like seven kkk members in the
entire country and they're all in some
basement somewhere they're not leaving
any nasty notes on anybody's doorstep
so that's your first clue
and your second clue is that like every
single racist note that's been written
in the last 25 years has been a hoax
i'm still waiting for an example of one
real one
but then if if that's not enough to get
through to you the fact that uh this
this racist
ku klux klan member would describe
themselves in the note
says a bunch of racist stuff and then
signs it a six foot tall
racist white man
with a long red beard
p.s i don't live in this neighborhood
pps i am not the black woman three doors
down
that is not me
and yet this neighborhood was gripped in
fear uh and then yahoo news says that uh
the
the outcome
that anyone who's been paying attention
would expect
is unexpected who could have ever seen
this coming besides literally everyone
with a brain all right let's read now uh
from the youtube comments
who's rocking polka dot and flannel
shirts without shame
do you know their name
they're the sweet baby gang
okay so the good texan says matt walsh
does not own a stove oven or microwave
because canceling is a dish best served
cold
uh that's actually true i don't we well
we have a stove but we actually do not
own a microwave at all and this has been
a
a point of contention in my my house
we went through a period without a
microwave because ours broke or
something and we were just too lazy to
get a new one
and um
[Music]
my wife
i guess got you just like the idea of
this this was one of our just like a
small protest against modern society i
guess
and everyone has to have at least that
one modern convenience that they don't
use so they can
brag about it and so uh and so
microwaves became our thing i didn't
want them to be our thing i really like
microwaves
and uh but but so it's it's it's a
constant argument our house or my wife
just refuses to put a microwave in the
house so we so for that reason you're
actually right about that
um
all right
this is from uh this guy's the limit
says matt thought you deserve to know
planet fitness is a gym for snowflakes
they don't allow customers to bring
water over a certain volume a gallon is
gym timidating they say
they have lunk alarms which go off of a
lifter grunts or makes too loud a noise
they have donut and pizza days to
celebrate the milestones you've made
if you want to cancel you have to send
in a handwritten letter to top it off i
once asked another customer after about
two weeks of attending if he knows where
there's a scale and he said do you not
know they don't have scales of planet
fitness because it may offend people
well
i'm not going to take this kind of
slander of
one of our great sponsors which is which
is planet fitness and listen i've been
to planet fitness i've nev i know they
have the lunk alarm i've never seen it
go off
and if they do use it they have good
reason to use it
don't be a don't be a lunk at the gym
whatever exactly that is
let's see
another comment says matt you said that
you haven't seen a great film in several
years what about the green book or 1917
haven't seen the green book but i have
seen 1917 and uh that was a few years
ago i think it's been a few it's been i
said it's been a few years since i've
seen a great movie and that might be the
most recent great one that i've seen um
i thought 1917 is a very good
film and war film and what i what i like
about it as a war movie
is the is the simplicity of it
because these days with you know two to
my favorite john my two favorite genres
war films and westerns and the problem
with hollywood now is they they they
think that if they make either of those
kinds of movies they have to kind of
like especially with westerns this is a
problem but you see with war movies too
they feel like they have to deconstruct
the genre and they have to do all these
groundbreaking things rather than just
make the movie and tell the story within
the
within the constructs of that genre but
uh 1917 they don't do do that
it's a war film it's a very simple story
but also a compelling one
and uh yeah that's a great one if you
haven't seen it
uh let's see michael says i like ties
and all but who the hell was the first
person to decide to hang fabric around
their neck and also said it looked good
uh yeah i don't like ties at all this is
why women need to stop complaining about
they say oh women are you know we have
childbirth and everything okay
you have childbirth allegedly
i'm told these days men can give birth
too so i'm not even sure if that's true
but
uh
even for the sake of argument let's say
only women can get can give birth so
you've got that okay that's that is a
burden you have to carry
i don't envy that
um in fact i quite enjoy
the fact that i'm not the one who has to
carry children and give birth to them
but
think about it formal occasions
you know you can
wear outfits that are appropriate for
the season
you know you can take a look outside
look at the weather look at the
temperature and say oh this is what i'll
wear you know it's hot out i'll wear
something a little bit lighter
but for for us we only have for formal
occasions we just have the one thing we
only have one option and it's a suit
so at a minimum we're wearing two layers
if it's 112 degrees outside doesn't
matter and you got to wear the the
the tie around your neck choking
yourself half to death
that's a cross wheat bear ladies that
you you don't know anything about that
uh let's see
this is from uh todd what did you think
of the ravens patting their stats at the
end of the broncos game yesterday
classless move oh i thought it was great
yeah the ravens played the broncos
yesterday and they they had the game
fully in in the bag they had won the
games about three seconds left in the
game and they were up by like two scores
and they had the ball you know in
football the tradition is
if in a situation like that you just
take a knee let the clock run out you
don't keep running plays because you've
already won the game well the ravens had
a
record on the line where they were
one away
from tying the steelers with the most
100 yard russian games in a row they had
like 42 of the steelers in 1970
something had 43 and so they were one
away
uh and at this point in the game they
had 97 yards rushing and so the head
coach john hubba harbaugh ran a play to
try to get those extra yards to get the
uh to get the the record and they did it
they got five yards and got the record
and there's been complaints about that
oh it's classless i don't want to hear
about that
especially from other players and
coaches complaining about it
you play a game for a living
number one
number two if you don't like it stop
them
so i don't believe in that taking a knee
you know you play to the whistle
that's it
and uh let's see
oh maximilian says matt your sweet
babies are worried you haven't given us
an update on poo for months
yeah well maximilian i haven't talked
about it because it's too painful
all right my guy poo
sheisty is in jail he's facing federal
charges
is this do do you want to bring this up
now this traumatic thing for me
in the middle of the show
and they're trying to pin everything on
them
i mean poo would never hurt a fly
certainly he would never steal drugs
from a fly and that's what they're
claiming he did it's ridiculous
i mean where would a fly even keep drugs
to begin with so the whole thing's a
mess it's a set up
and uh they're trying to take push isd
down
you want you wanted you want to see me
cry is that is that what this is about
maximilian
i'm not going to give you that
satisfaction
you're banned from the show you know if
you're one of the millions of americans
male or female who deals with bags and
puffiness under the eyes let me tell you
about genus cell from chamonix genus
cell serum also uses plant stem cell
technology to promote visibly healthier
skin and the appearance of younger
healthier eyes genusell's
state-of-the-art technology will become
your most powerful weapon against under
eye bags and puffiness customers
everywhere have been raving about this
product uh that includes my assistant
tessa who every day when i when i go
into the office and i see her you know i
say you must be using the genusel
there's no eye bags there it's kind of a
weird conversation to have with your
assistant but that's what we talk about
with this instant effects you see
results in the first 12 hours of your
money or your money back they guarantee
it you can order now and save big on
genusell's risk-free introductory offer
all orders are up to 50 off so if you
want to take advantage of this offer you
got to go to genusell.com and enter
mat30 for an extra thirty dollars off
again go to genusell.com enter mat30 get
that extra thirty dollars off that's
genusell.com
genusell.com let's take a guitar daily
cancellation
[Music]
so for our daily cancellation day we
have an onion of stupid with layers that
we must peel our way through one by one
we start with a priest by the name of
thomas reese who a few days ago shared
an article from religion news titled
why our preferred pronouns for god
should be they
now if you know anything about these
matters you've already guessed that
reese is a jesuit he's also an author
with a large social media following the
article in question was written by a guy
named mark silk who is according to his
bio the professor and director of
greenberg center for the study of
religion in public life at trinity
college as well as an editor for
religion news now he begins his screed
writing
he says quote writing last week in the
new york times linguistic professor john
mcwhorter waxed enthusiastic about the
advent of they as our all-purpose
third-person singular pronoun
now we'll get back to the blasphemy in
the first article in just a moment but i
want to take a step to the side here to
read a few lines from that new york
times article first as it apparently
inspired the other one that piece is
titled gender pronouns are changing it's
exhilarating
and this alleged linguistic professor
writes
the other day i had occasion to use the
pronoun they in the new way referring to
a specific person not your grandfather's
father singular they with its generic
meaning
a student can hand their paper in early
if they want to
but they as in roberto wants a haircut
and they also want some highlights
i wangled it
wangled
i don't know what that means but it
required a bit of conscious effort
pronouns sit deeply in our cognition
used constantly and bound by habit
it's their turn to use the kite don't
you think
i said thinking consciously about my
sentence in a way that i don't have to
usually
i know some find it wearying why does
language have to change all the time
with all we have to think about but
we're not unique there are times when
the language firmament shifts under
people's feet and they get through it
and then he goes through a number of
examples of times when language has
changed in the past insisting that this
is no different and he wraps it up this
way says
they tell you mountains become sand but
you never get to see it language change
happens faster and you actually get to
get to witness it it's something to
treasure
yes you see it is in fact a great
privilege to have a bunch of people with
blue hair and nose piercings make up new
rules of grammar on the spot and demand
that you follow them
it is exhilarating and majestic like
watching mountains become sand
granted some of the people in this group
uh may have the girth of mountains but
the comparison still seems like a
stretch and anyway i'll have more to say
about the you know in response to that
but first let's get back to mark silk
over at religion religion news who in
his article
inspired by this new york times piece
writes quote
in contrast to being humans it has long
been accepted that god is not gendered
at least within the within the main
abrahamic theological tradition a phrase
such as god the father should be treated
as a metaphor and for those concerned
about the embedded misogyny of the
tradition to say nothing of post-binary
folks a deeply problematic one as a
result we have been faced liturgically
as well as theologically with the
imperative of gender-neutral language
which means being obliged to repeat the
word god where a gendered pronoun would
normally be used and to have recourse to
the unattractive nilogism god self
lest god forbid we find ourselves saying
himself
they theirs them and themself or maybe
themselves solves the problem as in
praise god for whom all blessings flow
praise them all creatures here below etc
all right now that we have the whole
picture here confused as it is
um a few responses
first on the issue of language evolution
in general we must continue to note that
this pronoun stuff is not a natural
evolution
it's true that language changes over
time
language is fluid in that way
language is a symbol it's a sound meant
to represent something
you could argue that language is
fundamentally arbitrary in that way
we say elephant to talk about elephants
and camels to talk about camels but
things could have worked out so that we
say camels to talk about animals we now
call it elephant and elephants for
camels there's no reason why we had to
use the particular sounds we used to
represent those animals that's just how
it worked out
that's why language can shift and change
over time that's true
now in the times article many examples
are given of past shifts in language
it's argued that what we're experiencing
today is just more of the same
but it's not it's very different
because most changes in language happen
relatively organically
due to a wide combination of influences
people begin to slightly adjust the
verbal symbols they use for certain
things and eventually the official
grammatical rules as written in grammar
textbooks and so forth will change also
but they change descriptively not
proscriptively they are describing and
codifying a change that is already
underway
what's happening with pronouns is not
like this rather it's a top-down change
the grammar rules are being changed
prescriptively
our cultural elites have decided for
ideological reasons that we ought to be
using different words and they plan to
berate and scold and punish us until we
comply
this is not a natural evolution of
language this is an intentional
manipulation of language which is a very
different thing so just like what
they're doing with the with the made-up
nonsensical word la tinx
or latinx
nobody in that community uses the word
or likes it yet the cultural elites keep
using it and pushing it and pushing it
hoping that eventually people will
submit and start adopt adopting it in
daily use if and when that day happens
they'll then turn around and say look at
that language evolved
but calling that natural evolution is
like injecting drugs into a lab rat and
calling it natural evolution when it
grows a third ear
now there have been other examples of
this kind of unnatural imposed evolution
of language the times piece mentions a
few like when african-american became
the preferred term in the 90s to
supplant black then we went back to
black again which was then replaced by
people of color which is considered
politically correct while colored people
is horrifically racist all of that is
arbitrary and ludicrous and it's mostly
the result of cultural elites again
telling us what words we should be using
and yet even this isn't as bad as the
pronoun changes because in this case the
verbal symbols to describe a certain
reality
are are being changed but with the
pronouns they wish to change the symbols
and the thing that's being symbolized
the point of making pronouns fluid and
genderless is to give the impression
that people people are fluid and
genderless
they're not just trying to change the
way we describe thing things they're
also trying to change that which is
being described overall you know
language is supposed to convey meaning
language if it changes is supposed to
change in order to make meaning more
clear but in this case language is
changing in order to make our meaning
more obscure that's the difference and
it's a pretty big difference
and that brings us to the issue of god's
pronouns
notice how the article refers to our
preferred pronouns for god that's
instructive because the author doesn't
seem concerned with god's preferred
pronouns for himself
on that end if you're an adherent to any
of the abrahamic religions there's no
question about it god prefers to be
referred to as he
that's how his book refers to him
that's what his prophets call him and if
you're a christian you know that the son
of god emphasis on son here
not only called god father but also
was himself a hymn
it's true that god has no biological sex
because god created biological sex he
created biology he transcends male or
female
he does we don't
and yet god wants us to understand his
relationship to us as that of a father
to his children do i fully understand
what that means
can i fully comprehend that cosmic
analogy no neither can you but that's
what god has told us and that's what
he's given us
i find it quite telling that according
to some people like the writer of this
article and the priest who shared it
we should respect everybody's preferred
pronouns except for god
for him we can impose our own onto him
we have our preferred pronouns for him
rather than respecting the ones that he
prefers for himself
because that's what all of this is
really about in the end isn't it
it's about putting us at the center and
what we want at the center
rather than subjecting ourselves to any
greater truth
like god or even like grammar
and that's why everyone associated
with that article they're all
canceled
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover
our technical director is austin stevens
production manager pavel vadosky the
show is edited by ali hinkle
our audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair makeup is done by cherokee heart
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matt wall show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 21.
an illegal alien harasses a u.s senator
in women's bathroom dr fauci tries to
cancel christmas again and a democrat
lawmaker claims that efforts to stop the
killing of black babies
are rooted in white supremacy check it
out on the michael knoll show